Hello everyone, my name is Ashish Kumar and I'm a final year student here at IIT Kharagpur
and I'm pursuing my bachelor's and master's with master's in AI and ML.
So we'll go through this tutorial.
This will discuss about how can we use Mistral for inference.
Then we'll discuss about the intuition about tokenizer, what is zero short prompting, few
short and channel thought prompting and finally about function calling.
So let's start with how can we load the model.
So first you need to install these required libraries, like transform, accelerate and
toss vision.
And then you can use these modules in these specific libraries to load the model.
So here we have specified the model name, which you can get from here, model repo link.
And since it's a dated model, after you log in, you need to get some special permissions
on the model space.
So after accepting, you'll be able to access a model.
But how do you load it here?
You need to have a hugging face token and the steps to derive it is mentioned in this video.
You can follow this to get the answer of how to get the token.
And here we have specified the device map to be auto.
It automatically selects all available set of CPU and GPUs and load the safe tensors on
the devices that you have.
So here we load the model and tokenizer and then we define the pipeline.
So the pipeline is for, as here it's for text generation, we specify the model and the tokenizer.
And then we mentioned these parameters, temperature, the randomness in the generated output, the
top P, which is sampling from all those set of tokens whose cumulative probability is
sum up to 0.85.
Top K is sampling from top 10 tokens and max new tokens is how much additional tokens
to be required, apart from what we are passing as input.
So now we'll set up the system and user prompts.
In the, this is set in this way, we define the role here for the system and we are saying
that you are a helpful medical assistant chatbot, you provide accurate and informative responses
to medical questions.
And then this is the user prompt, that is what is the symptom of the flu.
And this whole set of message go to our pipeline which we created, which is this one.
And it generates a response in this format in which we have the initial system prompt
and the user prompt and what is generated by the assistant.
So, whatever the model responds based on our system user prompt, it's present in this content
field and the model respond to the question that the symptom of the flu, also known as
influenza, typically includes, and it answers the question.
Now we saw about inference, let's see about mister tokenizer.
So for example, if say we have the input, this prompt engineering course is offered by AI
for ICPS, let's learn about tokenizer and tokens.
This when passed to the tokenizer, what it does is, it stores that in this format.
We have input IDs and attention marks.
Now this input IDs is important because when we are passing the text, what model sees are
these numbers.
So what happens is, these text is converted to these numbers, passes to the model.
Model generates again numbers like this, which are again decoded back to the text.
Now we want to refer how these numbers corresponds to these tokens, we can see it here.
For example, this token ID corresponds to this beginning of sentence token.
Now 16119 corresponds to this and then prompt.
So this way there is a mapping, one-to-one mapping between all these token IDs and the
corresponding text.
And if you want to see the system prompt and the user prompt, how they are passed as a
representation of token IDs, here it's present, that for system access token you are a helpful
medical assistant, it was here.
So all these numbers are corresponding to these token IDs.
And similar for the user message token as well.
So we are converting all those text into these numbers, which are being passed to the model.
Model and for using these numbers, give some set of numbers again and based on that, it's
decoded back in some text.
Now let's look forward to this, some prompting methods.
First is zero-shot prompting, we specify the role that you are a math expert assistant
and then we ask the question, what is the result of 345 plus 789.
And the model gives the output as 1134, which is correct.
And in the few-shot prompting, what we are doing is we are giving some few set of examples
so that model can better understand the task and how can it give the, in what form it should
give the answer.
So here we have two kind of examples which we are giving that we are, firstly the system
prompt that you are a math expert assistant, then solve for this question, okay.
So it should give answers like this, the result is x is equal to 2.
Then we ask all for 3x minus 5, then the result is this.
And if we ask this question, what the model should generate?
And the model gives the output as, the result is x is equal to 6.
Now since the model follows the way in which the answer should be generated, but it's wrong
because the answer should be x is equal to 7, right, 4x is equal to 28, so x is equal
to 7.
So here we can see the beam error or limitation of the few-shot prompting as well.
It's not able to perform because it may be it's a complex reasoning task for the LLM.
And when we go to chain of thought prompting, what we are doing is we have the same questions
solved for, but here instead of just providing the direct answer, we are also providing the
reasoning and when we ask the same question again, which we asked in the few-shot prompting,
it says first subtract 2 from both sides, so it becomes 4x is equal to 28.
Now divide both sides by 4, so x is equal to 7.
So here we can see that, okay, based on what the few-shot prompting was not performing well
on the same question and answer, same question, chain of thought is able to perform really
good and able to give the correct answer.
Now let's go through the function calling.
So in function calling, essentially we have four steps, there are two scenarios as well.
Let's say if I'm a developer and I'm trying to test my pipeline, which I have built.
So I have specified the tools, the functions which are available to the LLM and if I ask
a question, hey, what's the temperature in Delhi right now, then what happens is based
on whatever I ask the question and the available set of information about the function it has,
it tries to pick the most relevant function and what arguments which can be passed to
that function.
The model generate those arguments and all those arguments are then passed in our system
and we execute the function to obtain those results and then we combine all of it, the
initial question which was asked, the tool information which was generated by the LLM,
the answer by, after execution of the tool, we get all of that and we pass it to the model
again and then model generates a coherent response in plain text which can be very easily
deciphered by the user.
So let's start step by step, we'll go through each one of them in detail.
So we have, first what we do is we specify the available information about the functions.
Here we have defined two dummy functions, getCurrentTemperature and getCurrentBendSpeed.
They are two arguments mentioned, location and unit and in current withSpeed its location.
We are using a dummy function, you can replace it by your own API which can retrieve real-time
information about it and we also specify what this function does, what kind of argument
it expects and what does that mean and what can it return.
So this whole information when we are appending to the model, this whole information is very
relevant for the model to understand what kind of argument shall it generate based on
this user query, it needs to extract from this.
So next what we do is we specify the role and our question that you are about that response
to weather queries, you should reply with the unit used in the queried location.
So this is the system prompt and we ask the question, hey what's the temperature in Delhi
right now?
So this is our question.
So if we see it first time, hey what's the temperature in Delhi, Delhi seems like a fair
argument because in our function we have an argument for location.
So essentially the model should extract the location to be Delhi.
So what model does is model first selects, we had two functions, getCurrentTemperature
and getCurrentBendSpeed, so the user is asking about the temperature in Delhi, so it should
select getCurrentTemperature function and the location is extracted to be Delhi, Annotate
Celsius.
And here is how we pass all this information to the model.
In the inputs, first we apply our chat template by a tokenizer, we pass the message, both
the system and user prompt and the list of available tools here, okay.
So it carries all those information about the functions which we have and then we are
asking, okay, it should generate based on, it should have this generation prompt to be
true.
Returning it should, returning the dictionary format and it should also return the tensors.
And then we pass this to the model and we generate the output, we decode back the output
using the tokenizer as we discussed previously.
And then we get the response, okay.
So the response is, may not, it's not visible, but this is the response, this is the way
in which you get the response, you get the function name and the argument, okay.
So once you get the function name and argument, you need to execute it, right.
Here in Mistral, there is a specific requirement, you need to generate a particular tool called
ID and append it along with the message when you are passing it finally.
So here you can generate it like this, it's a random number and you also pass the response
generated by the LLM, okay.
So this is the final set of message, it's visible here.
Here we have the tool called ID and the argument and the function which model wants to execute.
Now here you can see that it's in the string format, okay, and we need to convert it into
JSON, you need to decode it using some JSON format so that we can run it on our system.
So here the code loads the response, and in case it cannot, there is one more complex
function which can decipher that string to convert into that format.
So here you can see that when we pass this string, it's able to generate it into a dictionary
format.
Now it's, we are ready for executing this on our local machine.
So here you can see that we try to get the name of the function and the argument and
if the name was current temperature, we pass the argument and we get the results, okay,
and we append it here in the content part, okay.
And if it was get current wind speed which is not, and this example, we follow the same
procedure and we get the results of the execution of this function, okay.
Now this whole thing needs to be combined, whatever initial question was asked, the system
prompt, the information about the tool and the function which was given by the LLM, the
execution results, all these are combined and sent to the model again.
So you can see we are passing it, we are first tokenizing it and then we are passing it as
an input to the model.
And then model generates a final answer based on all these information at once.
And as you can see here, the current temperature in there is 30 degrees Celsius.
So if I am an end user and there is a developer, the developer has already specified this whole
pipeline and if the user asked that he was temperature in Delhi right now, the end user
gets the response directly that the current temperature in Delhi is 30 degrees Celsius
and everything else is happening in the back end about selection of the function, the argument,
execution, the combining and getting the final answer, right.
So this is how it goes and finally we get the final, hope that it was useful and thank
you.